I just want to start off this video
by saying I am deeply, deeply sorry.
I've been deceiving you guys
for the last two years.
You all think I live in this nice place
with this nice brick fireplace,
but this room is actually
a total mess.
So when we moved in here,
we had so many plans for this room,
we were going to use it for hanging out,
for watching TV, for reading,
but then I started my YouTube channel
and it just kind of became a filming room
and I just totally neglected it
pretty badly.
And it's been being used for just storage
pretty much.
So now we're finally taking the step
to make this place a little bit nicer.
And so today I want to show you my thought
process for transforming this place
into a more livable and functional space
by just using my iPad.
A portion of this video is sponsored
by Wayfair.
More on their awesome
YouTube series later in this video.
As I've mentioned
in some of my other videos,
my design workflow has changed completely
since I got my iPad.
I use a combination of procreate
and more folio for most of my design work,
and if you want you can check out
some of the brushes and backgrounds
that I use on a daily basis
in the link, in the description.
So I have gone ahead
and cleaned up the room
a little bit
just so that I can show you around.
And so I do have a fairly
interesting
set of constraints in this room.
So the filming room is in the basement.
So first of all, it's got a pretty low
ceiling height.
It's about eight feet, which is about
2.4 meters for the rest of the world.
And I have this very narrow
strip window and very little daylight,
which is actually perfect
for filming over here.
I have my filming setup,
which is constantly, constantly a mess.
I've got my camera and my
equipment, my lenses, my cables
all on this shelf,
and I have my camera right in the center.
And sometimes Raf will sit here
and hold me.
And typically, I'll have, like,
a bunch of lights around here,
and I'm like, sitting here with my laptop
and my notes
and I do like to keep the set up
fairly permanent
because it just removes
a lot of the friction out of filming.
And if any of you guys are interested
in starting YouTube channels,
I feel like that's
one of the easiest things
that you can do
to keep your videos consistent.
Just to have like a permanent setup.
And over here, I have the couch right now
and I have this really ugly bulkhead
sticking down
and it brings down the ceiling
to about six foot eight.
I think that's about two meters.
And it is in the same datum
as the top of this window.
So because this room feels very like
fragmented right now,
I'm going to try to use this datum
to try to create
a little bit of order in the space.
And, of course, over here
I have my filming backdrop,
and I am kind of considering
whitewashing this.
I don't know.
I'm getting a little bit
sick of this red fireplace.
Are you guys getting a little bit
sick of it?
I'm getting a little bit sick of it.
So we'll see.
But even when I'm not filming,
it is kind of the hearth of this room.
It's the place
where your eyes are naturally drawn
to when you enter the room.
And because the space is quite small,
with a fairly low ceiling height,
I want to visually extend
the length of this room a little bit.
And when I first moved in here,
that was the intent of these low
horizontal shelves.
We just cut up some wooden panels
and set them on these concrete blocks.
But over time,
we realized that they're great
for displaying things,
but they're not very functional
and the spaces got really messy,
really fast.
So before I had my iPad,
I would have probably drawn up
an actual true elevation
and started sketching on that.
But these days I find it
the easiest to just like take a photo
and start sketching on top of that.
This way I can really just
quickly sketch out some ideas and see
which ones I want to develop further,
whether it's in a 3D model or in a render.
And it's a really fast way
for me to try out different options.
And as I'm doing this,
I am simultaneously going on Pinterest
and picking out some inspiration
images for the room, because that's,
I think, one of the most fun parts
of an interior design project.
I think my style preference is somewhere
between mid-century
modern and Scandinavian,
but I also love the rough natural textures
of that Mediterranean
or the Japanese wabi sabi look.
But as I was finding these images,
I kept seeing the term Japan,
the independiente of Handy, and I discover
that there is a very specific style.
That's the perfect combination
of all of these.
And actually, I learned this
through Wayfair's YouTube channel.
I knew Wayfair as a website
where you can buy affordable, chic
looking furniture, but I never knew that
they had an educational YouTube channel.
They have a new series called
A Style is Born, where they discuss
how and why certain styles came to be.
I love how they break down the history
of that style from the social
and economic conditions
and why it's making a comeback.
And I think when you understand
the context behind something,
you can appreciate it a lot more beyond
just the esthetics of it.
It can also help you understand
why you're drawn to that specific chair
or table or vase.
Anyways, I would highly recommend
you check out their episode on Japan.
It's really well produce, it's really well
researched and it's really fun to watch.
So yeah, go subscribe to their channel.
It's full of really great content.
All include the link in the description.
So I'm going to put this photo
on as my bass player and the first thing
that I do is I'm going to set up the grids
and I'm going to use this
to set up my baselines
and then I adjust the photo
to have straight horizontals and verticals
as much as possible
without going into Photoshop
and fixing up the photo.
And then I'll put on the perspective grid
and I'm just going to leave this
on throughout the duration
of this process, try to align
the perspective lines as best as you can
and create another layer on top.
So this layer is going to be your base,
outline your walls and your doors
or your windows and basically elements
that are already in the space.
Once you do this, you're going to have
some lines that naturally come out,
and I'm using that as my starting point
for the design.
We've got the strip window
and this bulkhead that are kind of more
or less on the same level.
And we also have this wall
that drags in a couple of inches.
And because this room
has a lot of fragmented elements,
I want to use this as a datum
to try to bring
some order into the space
before I start sketching.
I draw out a very rough
plan of the options I want to look at.
I'm going to need about eight boxes.
Those are Kallax boxes of storage,
which probably means
I should get about 12 to 16
because, you know, I want to be realistic.
I think a good rule of thumb
for life is to account
for double the amount of storage
that you think you're going to need.
So I want to explore an option
where I have a large storage unit
that goes up to this wall
jog and an option where I have low storage
units broken up into two sections and
maybe I'll do some iterations off of that.
I'll have my desk
and my camera set up right here,
and sometimes my partner sits right
next to the camera to help me film.
And so if you have these non-negotiable
constraints like this,
you can just put them
right into the base drawing.
So this large storage unit,
I'd align it for our datum,
and maybe this corner
can be its own thing.
So what I'm doing here with the curtains
is I'm pulling it just past my window
all the way to the end of the wall.
So it looks like the window continues
all the way through.
And I'm starting the curtain right
from the ceiling all the way to the floor.
So it adds some height to the space.
But as you can see already,
I think the storage unit is a little bit
big for the space,
especially because we've got this very low
ceiling height and it's already starting
to feel a little bit overwhelming.
So we can try something
a little bit smaller,
but that just doesn't really work
with any of the grids.
So it just looks a little bit
awkward in the space.
I think a lower storage works
a lot better with the proportions
of this particular space, maybe
with a wall shelf along the state m line.
And you can see how I've done something
really similar with my home office,
which is also really fragmented.
Like there's a window
that's off the center, there's
this bulkhead and there's doors
in kind of awkward places.
But in this case, I was able to create
a continuous perimeter with the shelving,
so I decided to put lights to up
like the ceiling
and give the illusion of a taller space.
But with this room, I'm
not going to be able to continue this line
across the room,
so I'm not going to be updating this.
And instead I'm probably
going to use it for storing books
or my models
or anything that I don't reach
on a very regular basis.
So proportionally, I think these smaller
shelves work a lot better.
So I like how this option's
creating its own little zone,
and I'll probably put it in like an area
rug just to emphasize this
filming zone, by the way,
I'm just drawing this furniture
in as placeholders,
but I am going to go through the process
of selecting the furniture later,
but probably I'm going to go with IKEA
shelving anyways
because it's the most cost effective
and I don't want to spend
a ton of money on the space.
I'm going to try
flipping the TV and the couch
so that when you walk
in, you see the couch instead of the TV.
I kind of like this arrangement
because it creates more of an enclosure
and I might end up changing it like this.
So I kind of go back and forth
between these different elevations
just to make sure that the space
feels coherent as a whole.
Once I've got this design to the level
I want, I model this
and to sketch up
with some generic furniture blocks
just to get
a more accurate sense of scale.
So as you can see,
I've created a little bit
more order into the space
by creating some continue lines
with these shelves and by reinforcing
symmetry with the artwork.
I'm also trying to make the space
feel a little bit more open by using low
furniture elements and a scones around
eye level to bring down the sight line.
And I've added some tall artworks
and tall curtains to elongate the space
a little bit.
I'm also creating two zones
with the shelving and the area rug.
In the next phase,
I'm going to go through the process
of developing a mood board
and a material palette.
And at that point,
I'm also going to print out
the perspectives from the SketchUp model
to play around with the materials
so that I know exactly what pieces
I should buy before going to the store.
If you're interested in this procreate
brush pack, I have everything from pens
to markers
to brushes as well as to people's slides.
I'm going to leave that
in the description.
If you have any questions on anything that
I went through today, just let me know.
Down at the comments.
And if you like this video, please
give me a thumbs up and stay tuned
for the rest of the renovation.
It's going to be very exciting
and I will see you in the
next video.